it's like 95 degrees out in l.a right
now
the power of suck
is strong i think it's time that i slurp
myself
i don't know how much you follow about
this unless you're following the vlogs
on quarterdigital.com we actually are
moving back into studio three there used
to be a cupboard here and the fridge
went right here remember when the fridge
door would break anytime we went to the
fridge well that was right here so our
fridge is now displaced all the way over
here
um and inside the freezer
we don't get much
it's it's like 95 degrees out in l.a
right now you know it's hot enough that
i want a cold beverage but the problem
is that like none of these things can
keep my drink cold sure they can
it's cold
[Music]
this is the worst ice ever
this ice is impure and i can't afford to
buy new ice
okay i could buy a new ice tray but
that's no fun and we're here on this
channel to have fun so i decided to use
my 3d printer and a new vacuformer to
make a new ice tray of my friend's heads
and hopefully at the end of all that
i'll be able to enjoy a nice cold drink
and who knows maybe we'll be able to
make some other things like maybe some
jello or chocolate like
the way i'm going to make ice cubes of
all of us is i'm going to start by using
this free app on your iphone called
bellus 3d i've used it twice before once
to make my head for our pinewood derby
car oh i have that head so it's kind of
broken because i threw it on the ground
but it's me can't you tell this is me
back when i still had hair bellas uses
these special fancy little sensors that
are used to like face id and unlock your
phone to create a 3d mesh of your face
while also projecting an image of your
face onto that and just like that this
is the face of someone who has a nice
cold drink i now have a 3d model of my
head i can export it as an obj or an stl
file
so now i guess we can scan the guys
[Music]
okay now you do it
it's gonna mix you guys oh it is
what okay look at it from there
oh my god that's so weird it's peter
until you look too much to the left and
then it's me
[Music]
hey that's good that'll work it'll
probably work love it all right niko
[Music]
it looks really good actually that's
pretty solid i think we can totally
print that why does the ice cream taste
so good
well it's because it's so cool
all right nick did you want to get a
face scan sure yeah do uh do it do a
youtube thumbnail expression
[Laughter]
oh yeah of course
after scanning everyone's faces in
bella's 3d i was able to import those
models into cinema 40 where i needed to
make some important tweaks to get them
ready for the forming process it's
incredibly important to make sure that
there are no overhangs in the model
otherwise i wouldn't be able to remove
it from the mold itself because you know
it'd be stuck
so i had this stuff print overnight
and i got a couple different heads so
this one printed in two hours this one
printed in eight hours two different
sizes of ice cubes here this one might
be a little harder to put a drink when i
previously tried printing some ice cube
molds i printed with this material
called tpu ninjaflex specifically which
is a flexible type of plastic that
didn't work very well because the prints
were very leaky so all the water leaked
out before it was able to freeze
so i'm gonna try something new today
using this
vacuum former and i know it just looks
like a cardboard box but i'll let me
open it up first and then we'll talk
about it what is a vacuum former you
might ask well imagine taking a sheet of
plastic melting it putting it around an
object and then sucking all the air out
of it so it form fits to that object but
then that plastic hardens and then it's
like a nice little piece of uh mold this
is the form box from meiku
it is a desktop sized vacuum farmer it
means you don't have to spend thousands
of dollars on like a huge vacuum former
if you just want to vacuum form just
like small little pieces i'm i'm very
excited about this i've never had a
vacuum farmer before this is like some
adam savage stuff here
ah look at that
this is a tube
that's a tube it's a tool
look at the size of the power company
they are expecting some amps okay so now
i've gotta actually figure out how to do
this i don't think it'll be too hard to
figure out and once i do i'm gonna get
my face in there like this
and
make a mold out of it just like that
hey guys i just got off the phone with
uh nico and ren and it sounds like
they're creating heads
out of ice
and uh it sounds really complicated one
thing that's not complicated is using
today's sponsor squarespace because they
have beautiful award-winning templates
and 24 7 award-winning customer service
it sounds pretty simple it's about as
simple as squarespace's multiple
contributors tool to use you can have
different people contribute different
things to your site with different
levels of access the next thing that
squarespace has is the traffic overviews
tool you can traffic overview your own
website and see where people come from
what people utilize your site for and
how to make it better squarespace has
audio blocks feature which allows you to
post things like podcasts on your site
and last but not least squarespace has
simultaneous posting features which
means that you can post one time on
squarespace and it'll automatically go
out to like your twitter and facebook
profiles and automatically format in
accordance with those profiles
hey man are you at the studio uh yes and
i heard you were 3d scanning people's
faces and stuff yeah yeah that's pretty
complicated and the thing that i was
trying to get across was like nothing is
easier than using squarespace i mean i
could see that yeah there's a lot of
complexity with what i'm doing it sounds
like you've just got to figure it out
well i just want to let you know and uh
if you're interested head on over to
squarespace.com corridor
[Music]
that's right it's 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain what a
steal
great
i think that went well let's see uh
where they're at with their ice cubes
this is like one of the thickest cables
i've ever seen this is thicker than a
bowl of oatmeal
now we need our materials so this is a
sheet of plastic here that is going to
melt unclasp this
raise that up put the little piece of
plastic there so this sliding panel here
actually holds the plastic and
this thing heats the plastic evenly and
after about two minutes or so the
plastic is ready to uh be formed the
four box itself actually turns on the
shop vac because you plug the shop vac
into the vacuformer this is smart enough
to know exactly when to start applying
suction at the right moment we got the
shop vac we got the form box plugged in
and everything is connected the next
thing
for all instances and purposes this
thing's ready to go
all right
so also another concern is that this
might be too hot and might melt the 3d
print i think it'll be fine but we'll
find out
place this guy right in the middle here
well i can see it drooping oh there it
goes it's starting to droop oh it's
drooping it's drooping you ready yep yep
it's moving the truth
that looks great
the power of suck
okay i'll let that cool here dude oh my
god i am excited so now
comes the moment of truth can i even
remove this piece
it's coming there we go
[Music]
that's pretty good that's pretty good
there's that huge seam along my forehead
which sucks but
overall
it turned out great
so my two heads so far i'm actually
going to print all four of our heads
even smaller than this one so that it's
actually even more ice cube size
something that can fit in a glass that
way i can print all four of these heads
in the same print session and also be
able to put all four of these heads on
the same bed to make the same tray so
that way i can actually have one single
ice tray with all four of our heads the
four cubesmen of the icepocalypse
all right the video's over
[Music]
so with the ice cube trays ready to go i
decided to create even bigger molds with
scaled-up head prints that way i can
surprise the guys with some bonus
treats so after everything is done and
in the refrigerator i'll bring them in
to show the guys
you guys are all looking a little
parched it's a little hot out yeah we
need some glasses we need some water
peter
we got some ice we can each get our own
head twice what
nice
look it's a little me
[Music]
dude that's amazing
i'm gonna grab mine i think i broke mine
a little bit yeah mine broke a little
bit
here's me
oh wait can i hear your eyes
dude don't you see the resemblance
all good
so refreshing i can very easily just
print more of these heads and make an
entire tray of like a dozen ice cubes
on the website of quarter crew ice cube
trays leave a comment down below if you
want us to do that
why but okay
the great thing about this method is
that is a mold you can fill it with
anything and for so far what we've been
doing is we've been making ice cubes but
you can fill these molds with other
things and the very easy thing to do
well i'll show you i'll just show you
first off i'm going to show you
this one
you went crazy
so this one is actually already falling
out we'll do this one last
what's up nico
oh my gosh
look at the jiggle look at that jiggly
hey this is the first head that actually
has a semblance of
reality let's dig in
oh he's eating his chin
you're like eating your nose eat your
nose
look at this my god
it's really weird taking a bite of your
own face like it does feel weird do you
have more
that's really good actually let's see
what did your wife think of all this
she's just like classic
come on dude here i need to wait wait
wait wait wait no no
no
so for those i forgot to use cooking oil
but for this one i did not forget so
this one i have a feeling will come out
just fine
come on
[Applause]
i think it's time that i slurp myself
[Music]
you may have noticed that there's no
jello peter head
well i knew that peter does not like
jello i turned your head into a giant
frozen tomato soup bowl
i don't know how well this is going to
come out of the mold
look at that
god
i have my
all right peter i present you frozen
tomato soup i think thank you waiter
you're so lucky peter oh
wait bite your nose off
mmm
behind like freaking blast residue
oh my god
hey it's voldemort peter
voldemort peter
oh right through the nose
brainstorm this is weirdly cathartic is
no one else like emotionally creeped out
by the fact that like you're
getting all up on your own face
consuming it it's like a little weird
weird did you know it's super weird but
whoever gets a chance to do this sort of
thing i think the coolest part about
this whole thing is the fact that you're
easily able to make molds now we could
do so many things like prop wise novelty
wise with this absolutely anytime we
need to make like a hundred of something
we can just like we could design it in
3d print it out and then we can mold it
and then make hundreds of those things
that i printed
all right guys thanks for watching i'm
glad i could finally drink cold water
but it's not cold just yet the moment
i've been waiting for this whole time
so be sure to subscribe who knows what
we'll be doing next week we got crazy
wacky ideas all over the place
i'm drinking a glass of water with my
head as an ice cube i mean
how wild is that thanks for watching and
i'll see you in the next video